THE I MAY BE GOOGLY JUSTIN
BARRICK.IT’S EASY WHAT YOU ARE.
THE NEW DISTRICT ATTORNEY,
GEORGE HAS ANNOUNCED THAT
ENFORCING THE LAW IS RACIST.
TO FIGHT SYSTEMIC RACISM, GEORGE
IS DROPPING AND CUTTING INMATE’S
SENTENCES.
>> MY OFFICE WILL BEGIN AN
UNPRECEDENTED EFFORT TO
REEVALUATE EVERY SENTENCE.
RACISM AND THE DEATH PENALTY IN
OUR COUNTRY ARE CONSTRUCTIVELY
INCLINED TOINTERTWINED.IT IS RAC
IT IS IRREVERSIBLE AND
EXPENSIVE.
AND BEGINNING TODAY, IT’S OFF
THE TABLE.
>> Mark: TO DEMONSTRATE HIS
COMMITMENT TO "ANTIRACISM, THEY
MADE A BIG SHOW OF THE DISTRICT
ATTORNEY’S ASSOCIATION.
THE GROUP IS JUST TOO WHITE.
IT DOESN’T HAVE ENOUGH PEOPLE OF
COLOR.
BUT ACCORDING TO THE CALIFORNIA
DISTRICT ATTORNEY’S ASSOCIATION,
HE HASN’T BEEN A MEMBER FOR A
TERRIBLY LONG TIME.
VERN PEARSON JOINS US NOW.
IS THIS A DEVASTATING BLOW FOR
YOUR ORGANIZATION TO HAVE MISSED
IT ABANDONING IT?
>> WELL, NO IT’S NOT END THE
REASON IS THAT HE IS NO MORE
ABLE TO RESIGN FROM OUR
ASSOCIATION THEY HAD I AM ABLE
TO RESIGN FROM THE STARTING
LINEUP OF THE GIANTS.
HE IS NOT A MEMBER OF THE
ASSOCIATION NOR HAS HE BEEN A
MEMBER SINCE OCTOBER OF 2019
WHEN HE QUIT HIS JOB AS DISTRICT
ATTORNEY OF SAN FRANCISCO.
IT IS IMPORTANT TO NOTE THE
HYPOCRISY HERE.
HE IS RAISING THIS ISSUE IN THE
CONTEXT OF A PUBLICITY STUNT
REALLY.
A FEW WEEKS AGO, WE FILED IN
L.A. COUNTY IN SUPPORT OF A
LAWSUIT THAT ALLEGED THAT HE WAS
VIOLATING THE LAW.
HE, THE CHIEF PROSECUTOR IN
L.A. COUNTY WAS ALLEGED TO BE
VIOLATING THE LAW.
LASTLY, THE JUDGE CITED WITH US
AND THE DEPUTIES IN THAT LAWSUIT
AND HE SUPPOSEDLY RESIGNS FROM
OUR VERY DIVERSE ASSOCIATION IN
MEMBER FOR YEARS.
>> Mark: NOW, JUST TO BE CLEAR
ON THAT, THEN, WHY ISN’T HE A
LAUGHING STOCK IN CALIFORNIA?
AS YOU SAY, IT’S AN OBVIOUS
STUNT.
IT’S LIKE YOU RESIGNING FROM THE
GIANTS.
IT’S LIKE ME RESIGNING FROM THE
UNITED NATIONS SECURITY COUNCIL.
WHY ISN’T EVERYBODY JUST MAKING
HIM A COMPLETELY RIDICULOUS
FIGURE IN CALIFORNIAN PUBLIC
LIFE?
>> WELL, I THINK THAT’S
HAPPENING VERY QUICKLY.
LET’S TAKE A QUICK STEP BACK.
HE WAS APPOINTED DISTRICT
ATTORNEY IN SAN FRANCISCO IN
2011.
BY 2019, HE RESIGNED.
PROPERTY CRIMESS WERE UP BY 50%.
VIOLENT CRIMES WERE UP
SIGNIFICANTLY.
HE WAS SO UNPOPULAR WHEN HE
RESIGNED FROM SAN FRANCISCO, IT
WAS IMPOSSIBLE FOR HIM TO BE
REELECTED.
IN FACT, WHEN HE WAS MOVED TO
L.A. AND RAN FOR DISTRICT
ATTORNEY BACKED BY A HANDFUL OF
BILLIONAIRES INCLUDING GEORGE,
WHO FUNDED HIS CAMPAIGN, THE
AFRICAN-AMERICAN MAYOR OF
SAN FRANCISCO SUPPORTED HIS
OPPONENT.
SO NOW, WHAT WE ARE SEEING IS
THAT IT TOOK 7-YEAEARS FOR THE
PEOPLE OF SAN FRANCISCO TO
REALLY TURN ON HIM AND IN JUST A
VERY SHORT PERIOD OF TIME IN
L.A., THE PEOPLE ARE TURNING ON
HIM AND THERE IS A RECALL EFFORT
THAT IS ALREADY FORMING TO
RECALL HIM.
>> YEAH, LET’S HOPE THAT WORKS.
I DON’T THINK EVEN IN CALIFORNIA
CALIFORNIA --
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THAT AND
GREAT TO HAVE THE WORD FROM YOU.
HE IS RESIGNING.
IT’S LIKE A VARIATION.
NOT CARING TO BELONG TO A GROUP
THAT WOULD HAVE HIM AS A MEMBER.